if you want to get a monkey off your
back lop buri Thailand is not the place
to go every year on the last Sunday in
November the library in a local hotel
sponsors a festival just for the
resident macaque monkeys and there are
lots of them in the Buddhist tradition
the Thai Revere the monkey as a hero
according to legends the Monkey Hanuman
and his army saved a God's wife from the
clutches of a demon we believe that
Hanuman never died
so he's the symbol of prosperity and
good good luck and ever since the
monkeys of Thailand are free to roam and
don't have to worry about their next
meal every day people from the town
bring them food but on the day of the
festival near the camere temple the
spread is huge
including a colorful display of fruits
and goodies for the monkeys to choose
from and indulge even statues of monkeys
get trays of colorful food and a bottle
of water
the sponsor of all this monkey business
mr. young mute knows how to make an
entrance
organizers say the first purpose of the
festival is to feed the monkeys the
second what are tourists every year a
lot of people many people to delivery
for the see the monkey party
mischievous monkeys get into everything
and on anyone I was kneeling down taking
picture of a monkey and all of a sudden
monks wipe my my sunglasses off the
locals have to deal with the problems
too
ladies of all I just chased them away
from properties I don't shoot them I
just scare them we believe they belong
to the Monkey God
the main problem is they interrupt our
properties destroy electric wires and
telephone cables they cause problems but
the problems are overlooked and the
people go out of their way to make sure
the revered monkey stay healthy and well
fed so if you visit lop buri be sure to
have some extra food with you to share
with the local primates when people come
to visit here you could see the smile on
their face and if it's festival time
there's no telling what they'll have in
store
Nakia it up bigger than 10 - yeah - ah
you